einmal pro jahr darf jeder sein
geschlecht wechseln
es ist ein historisch neues gesetz ab
mitte nächsten jahres darf jeder ab 14
jahren geschlechtern vornamen auf dem
standesamt wechseln ja justizminister
marco buschmann und familienministerin
lisa paus die stellten die eckpunkte
jetzt vor einmal pro jahr also darf man
das geschlecht wechseln es ist eine
diskussion bei der schnell die gemüter
hochkochen eine diskussion die natürlich
auch viele fragen offen lässt was ist
zum beispiel mit öffentlichen toiletten
was gilt beim sport biologie oder der
selbstbestimmtheit
schauen wir uns einen ganz speziellen
fall an ein elf jahre alter junge der
sich als mädchen fühlt und deswegen mit
seiner mutter in einer transgender
klinik ist um dort hormone zu bekommen
dass wir irgendwann damit anfangen mir
bewusst ist auch der elfer bewusst nicht
was mit dem hormon lockern und dann
später mit den anderen hormonen weil
ansonsten gibt's
sonst
wissen junge besitz bleibt es also sonst
kommt der pubertät von jungen
willst du die pubertät vom jungen und
also deswegen haben wir es umgekehrt
schluss
müssen wir dann halt irgendwann anfangen
spitzen
kannst du denn da binär sexuell viele
begriffe die zu diesem thema einfach
dazugehören aber was genau bedeuten sie
eigentlich wie gut kennt sie sich
mittlerweile aus
intersexuell
transsexuell und pan sexuell alles
begriffe die man ja letzter zeit oft
gehört hat aber was bedeuten
was meinen sie was heißt intersexuell
keine ahnung hinter also intern hat es
auch etwas zu tun mit zwei geschlechtern
intersexuell
intersexuelle menschen haben körperliche
geschlechtsmerkmale die sich nicht als
nur männlich oder nur weidlich einordnen
lassen zum beispiel abweichung der
geschlechtschromosomen oder genetisch
bedingte hormonelle entwicklungsstörung
[Musik]
könnte ich nicht definieren also gehört
habe ich schon mal
kein sex kein zug kein identität als
wahnhaft alles
in alle richtungen alle richtungen offen
ich glaube dass man beide geschlechter
war das oder der dass man beide liebt
was meinst du was dann der unterschied
zu bisexuell wäre
kahn sexuell ist doch wenn man sich in
den menschen verliebt ohne geschlecht
hans sexuell sind personen die bei ihrer
sexuellen orientierung keine vorauswahl
nach geschlecht oder
geschlechtsidentität treffen
wenn man
sogar mal ein geschlecht aus andere
sicherung über nürnberg lassen
die richtung dass man sich im falschen
körper für zum beispiel und dann legen
von einem animierten oder umgekehrt
transsexualität ist der wunsch als
angehöriger eines anderen geschlechts zu
leben und anerkannt zu werden wir
haben sie die ganzen worte er noch nie
gehört ich glaube ich muss mich mal mit
sachen auseinandersetzen kann ich auch
nichts mit anfangen
das weiß ich selber nicht ich glaub ich
allgemein für die community ob man
homosexuelle sexuell anders ist
vielleicht als der durchschnitt
hier ist ein sammelbegriff für personen
deren geschlechtliche identität und oder
sexuelle orientierung nicht der zwei
geschlechtlichen norm entspricht
sie ist
hier ist cas fans nicht geregelt
ich glaube schon selbst was heißt es das
weiß ich nicht
es bedeutet dass man sich mit dem von
außen zugeschriebenen geschlecht dass
man bei der geburt bekommen hat
identifiziert
[Musik]
spannend ist ganz nah ich wusste auch
einiges davon gar nicht das hätten wir
also geklärt aber ist das neue gesetz
jetzt endlich ein offener weg für mehr
selbstbestimmtheit oder gibt es für sie
einfach nur mann frau und punkt ende aus
auch dazu haben wir uns in deutschland
und gerade da ja einmal im jahr macht
das keinen sinn jetzt anders im jahr
geändert wir ja heute auf morgen top
also dass das jeder selber entscheiden
wir derzeit laufen die ersten haben sich
wirklich zu finden also ich glaube wenn
es menschen gibt die den bedarf danach
haben gerne ja also ich
würde mich dadurch nicht beeinträchtigt
fühlen wenn das gut vielleicht einfacher
ist für menschen die sich im falschen
körper geboren fühlen und da was ändern
möchten wieso das ablaufen also wie soll
es ablaufen dass jeden tag jetzt gesagt
wird euch bin heute mal so ich bin mal
so also ich verstehe es könnte auch ein
ausmass nehmen und wir also dass sich
dann jeder irgendwie umbenennen will
jeder irgendwie das geschlecht wechseln
will vielleicht auch aus spaß oder so
kann ich nicht kann ich nicht
nachvollziehen tut mir leid das ist
nicht meine generation
sobald es keiner stört dass es mir ganz
egal wer mit wem schläft und wer sich
wie fällt bis mir ganz egal ich glaube
dass es gut wenn zum beispiel mein kind
erst jetzt ein junger aber wenn er mir
nach 14 jahren sagen dass er seinen
mädchen dann sage ich wir machen so ist
es dann sind wir für unsere kinder
zufrieden
ab 14 früh bin ich dafür ja da werden
schnell schnellschüsse gemacht oder auch
beeinflusst von anderen ich finde jeder
mensch auf seine art und weise geworden
und man sollte auch so bleiben also
jetzt kein ferner freuen wenn eine band
über schwer eine frau sein oder etwas
mehr man kann sich gar nicht
nachvollziehen
dabei reden wir denken also ich habe
nichts dagegen dass jemand seinen namen
oder identität oder also wenn man als
frau nicht identifizieren kann dass man
das irgendwann ändern kann aber nicht
dann ein jahr man einer frau und einem
jahr wenig lauter und einen tag bin ich
nämlich saß und das geht nicht toll fand
ich dieses eine elternpaar die bank
komplett entspannt wollen wir das thema
vertiefen mit anastasia wir fangen sie
ist die erste transgender kommandeuren
der bundeswehr und im vorsitz von queer
bw frau beer van schön dass sie da sind
ja was halten sie denn von den
eckpunkten dieses neuen selbstbestimmung
des gesetzes erst mal wunderschön guten
tag von mir ja ich bin hocherfreut
darüber dass ist das tier so weit ist
ich habe ich in meiner kolumne
geschrieben das transsexuellengesetz
gehört auf den müllhaufen der geschichte
befördert und es scheint so dass die
nächsten ein bis zwei jahren tatsächlich
passiert und dass wir weg von
priorisierung und stigmatisierung von
trans personen dieser gesellschaft
kommen und endlich einen
selbstbestimmten lebens weg gehen können
und der nicht mehr fremdbestimmt geprägt
ist insofern keine nur so grundsätzlich
begrüßen es wäre schön wenn dieser
legislaturperiode am anfang des jahres
hätte passieren können nicht erst bis
2023 aber ich glaube ist ein sehr guter
weg der aufgezeichnet wird und die
eckpunkte lassen darauf hoffen dass auch
ein gutes gesetz wird natürlich gibt es
auch dort verbesserungsbedarf das haben
wir auch schon andere verbände deutlich
aufgezeigt ein punkt den wir es auch
gerade im beitrag gesehen haben dass
sich manche darüber wundert warum man
dann jedes jahr die möglichkeit bekommt
nochmal geschlecht und name zu ändern
halten sie das für notwendig ich glaube
der der punkt ist der ansatz ist falsch
in dieser gerade reden es geht einfach
darum dass hier eine eine debatte früher
angefeuert worden ist die trans personen
und inter geschwächten personen binär
menschen unterstellt einfach dass wir
beliebig unser geschlecht wechseln
wollen wir einfach nicht wissen wir
unsere militär ist und ich glaube da
wollte man einfach dann aufbauen um auch
einer gewissen anderen öffentlichkeit
die einfach kein verständnis hat für die
lebenslage von ins bremer trans und
inter und normen binäre menschen sofort
zu kommen ich persönlich brauche dieses
jahres frist nicht weil ich weiß wer ich
bin und identität ist etwas was in ihnen
wächst ich mir ist noch keine trans
personen begegnen oder in binärer
personen oder auch in der stadt die
personen die den willen verspürt hat
alle jahre mal wieder wie sie so schön
ebenso sagen und wie ich finde sehr
diffamieren schreiben in ihrer headline
hier unten drunter mal eben das
geschlecht wechseln man wechselt sein
geschlecht nicht mal eben der auszüge
schon falsch also der konzern darüber
unterhalten mein persönlicher leidensweg
war sehr lange geprägt davon dass ich
mich in meinem geburtsjahr schlechten
ich wohl gefunden habe und die
gesellschaft mich einfach akzeptieren
konnte als das wie ich mich gefühlt habe
nämlich als frau und diesen weg zu gehen
selbstbestimmt zu gehen damit legen wir
es endlich an die grundlagen und
entgegen vieler politischer rhetorik die
auch ich sag mal für menschen verachten
ist geht es eben nicht darum mal eben
etwas zu wechseln es geht hier ein
selbstständiges gefühl über die eigene
die tat und die authentische
authentische und auch selbst bestimmtem
forderung nachzukommen dass ich in
dieser gesellschaft zu legen kann wie
ich mich fühle wie ich bin selbst wieder
andere zoos person auch nur ich bin halt
runs und andere menschen sind nun binär
und wir wollen einfach die gleichen
rechte haben wie alle anderen auch und
das ist glaube ich der kern des ganzen
da bin ich total ihrer meinung ich
glaube auch nur dass es sein kann dass
es viele menschen auf den plan ruft die
sich vielleicht auch ein scherz erlauben
damit was meinen sie
jedes gesetz kann ausgenutzt werden und
dafür wieder gesetzgeber sorgen dass das
nicht passiert und natürlich ist
entsprechend da ich kann nur sagen aus
der persönlichen erlebens perspektive
der menschen verdient dieses gesetz der
dann auch gemacht wird endlich ein weg
zu bereiten raus aus einer
stigmatisierung favorisierten ecke den
weg zu zeigen wer wirklich
menschenfreundlich menschen achten und
die menschenwürde auch achtet dann
endlich geschaffen wird und das schafft
man mit diesem gesetz und dass der
wichtige punkt und ich glaube die
menschen die wissen wie ihr geschlecht
ist und einfach abweichen von dem bus
geschlecht sind die stört das nicht dass
dort eine jahresfrist eingelegt worden
ist was entgegnen sie den menschen die
wir auch gerade in unserem beitrag
gesehen haben sie beispielsweise älter
sind und sagen das ist irgendwie ich
kann damit nichts anfangen frau mann
ende schluss mehr kenne ich jetzt nicht
mehr will ich auch gar nicht kennen
andere die sich gedanken machen was die
frauenquote betrifft oder was sind sport
beispielsweise betrifft was entgegnen
sie den menschen auch aus ihrem ganz
persönlichen erfahrungen ja ich würde es
ihnen erst mal erst mal begegnet man
einer person und auch auf dem ein land
zu einer kommunikation mit mir darüber
wenn überhaupt bin und dann glaube ich
auch unabhängig von alter kann man sich
einfach an der sichtweise öffnungen da
ist es geht ja nicht darum dass ich
etwas zu öffnen was da was neu ist
sondern einfach etwas war schon lange
gesellschaft realität ist nur etwas was
wir lange sei es einfach immer
stigmatisiert haben und auch
diskriminiert haben in den
gesellschaften und deswegen auf einfach
kein bewusstsein für diese lebenslagen
ist meine erfahrung ist in vielen fällen
ist einfach ein offener wertschätzender
umgang damit und entsprechend auch in
der bildungsarbeit frühzeitig damit
anfangen aufzuklären über dieses thema
schafft dann auch deutlich akzeptanz und
nicht nur toleranz und dann auch
wertschätzung und daran müssen wir
einfach arbeiten ich bin nicht dafür da
jeden menschen zu überzeugen
aber jeder mensch in dieser republik hat
einfach das recht selbst bestimmt und
glücklich und frei zu leben und das gilt
es dann einfach zu respektieren ich
glaube da sind wir uns auch alle einig
ihrer meinung würde mich noch
interessieren wir hatten ihm gerade auch
einen kleinen beitrag von einem elf
jahre alte mädchen ist in einer
transgender klinik ist eigentlich als
junge geboren möchte aber mädchen werden
und sitzt er mit ihrer mutter und sie
besprechen über eine hormontherapie wir
haben auch ich als mutter viel über
diese situation diskutiert denn auf der
einen seite möchte man nämlich genau
dass das was sie sagen man möchte sein
kind darin stärken fördern das zu sein
als dass es sich fühlt was es gerne sein
möchte und auf der anderen seite hatte
ich auch als mutter muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen so gewisse zweifel ob elf
jahre nicht ein bisschen früher moment
es damit zu beginnen auch hormone zu
spritzen das da habe ich ein bisschen
auch angst und sorge bekommen und mich
würde interessieren wie sie das sehen
wann ist der zeitpunkt zu beginnen da
auch medizinisch einzugreifen ich finde
völlig klar liegt auf der hand ganz früh
damit anzufangen zu stärken du bist der
du oder sie sich fühlt ganz klar und das
bist du und dafür lieben wir dich aber
wann geht man auch diesen weg
das ist glaube ich eine einfache frage
und ich bin kein erziehungsberechtigten
elternteil ich habe keine kinder
deswegen ist dann ich habe den beitrag
gesehen ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
war zu tränen gerührt hat sich die
mutter mit ihrer tochter gesehen habe
und ihren weg gehen können tatsächlich
ich weiß was es heißt wenn man im alter
von 40 erst damit anfängt und die weiß
was es heißt wenn man ein geschlechts an
reichende maßnahmen und medizinische
maßnahmen die übrigens nicht teil selbst
stimmungs gesetze sind sondern da gibt
es nach wie vor noch die gleichen
kriterien gemäss den fachleuten einen
weg zu gehen wenn dein körper sie schon
mit beginn der pubertät anfängt zu
verändern und in die richtung des
geburts geschlecht und wenn sie einfach
dann für sich empfinden das ist nicht
mein geschlecht also insofern ist
bestimmt keine einfachen frage und ich
glaube es ist auch für eltern keine
einfache entscheidung ich glaube was
dieser beitrag dabei gezeigt das ist
einfach dass ihre eltern sind die ihr
kind lieben und wertschätzen die
erfahrungen teilen und ohne angst um
diese kommunikation eingetreten diesen
weg zu begleiten und ich glaube da
schafft man dann einfach ein sehr gutes
bewusstsein dafür wo stehe ich dann wie
kann ich für mein kind da sein und was
möchte mein kind und ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher dass mit weiterhin auch
wissenschaft untersuchen und so weiter
und so fort und auch einfach viel mehr
erfahrung in diesem bereich wie auch
viel mehr auch evidenzbasiert dann damit
umgehen können dass dieser weg zum
gewissen zeitpunkt auch wenn er für
viele erstmal früheren ängstlich und
besondere erscheint tat sich ein guter
weg ist wenn alle beteiligten gemeinsam
wertschätzen und auch tatsächlich gut
informiert in so einem prozess
einsteigen der mit sicherheit für alle
beteiligten in dem fall kein leichter
ist aber schön daran dass haben sie
gezeigt seien sehr unterstützen da
prozess und da sahen sieht wie ich fande
zwei sehr glückliche menschen das stimmt
frau wir fangen vielen dank dass sie mit
uns gesprochen haben und dass sie uns
auch teilhaben lassen an ihrer
seelenwelt und dass sie auch vor allem
diese informationen in die welt tragen
ist glaube ich sehr wichtig an dieser
stelle danke schön liebe grüße